welcome to this simultaneous meeting of
baba district council cabinet
and mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley
leader of mid-southwark district council
and also in attendance is councillor
john ward
leader of baber district council we will
be jointly chairing the meeting today
however for reasons of efficiency i will
be leading the items
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons in the
chamber and
in the social areas please ensure that
you wear a mask unless you are sitting
down
or if you are unable to do so and that
you use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distancing at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov
app i would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
now gonna move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence thank you chair we
have received apologies from councillor
mccraw and councillor halt
thank you very much item two is to
receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
thank you item three mca
21-2 to confirm the minutes of the
mid-suffolk cabinet meeting held on the
5th of july 2021
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
could i have a proposal please
councillor hattingham thank you
and a second councillor richardson thank
you very much
the governance officer will now conduct
the vote
thank you chair your vote is now in
progress on your app
that is nine votes for chair
right we'll now move on to paper bca213
to confirm the minutes of the baba
cabinet meeting held on the 5th of july
2021 starting at page 7 of your report
pack
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of these minutes
in which case may i have a proposal
please counselorathy thank you
and the councilman of easy second thank
you very much so the governance officer
will now conduct the vote
the vote is now in progress on your app
chair that is six votes four thank you
moving on to item four is to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
none received jam thank you item five
questions by councillors
none received jam and item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committee
there are no matters referred chan thank
you
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list
does anyone have any comments on that
thank you item eight mca
21 13 and bca 21
14 is the general fund financial out
turn
for 2020 21 and i'm now going to invite
the mid-south cabinet member for finance
to introduce the mid-suffolk report
thank you
thank you madam chairman um i'm pleased
to introduce report
mca 21-13
on the general fund financial out turn
for 2021.
this exceptional covid 19 pandemic year
has impacted our income and expenditure
and you'll see
included in the report for this year
both an executive summary
within section four and a four page long
section five detailing the impact of
kovid 19.
i don't intend to go through those two
areas in a great deal of detail within
this introductory speech
the table in 5 10 being the covered
financial impact on mid suffolk
runs through an entire page with 27
various cost
income losses and funding support
suffice to say that what appeared at the
beginning of the pandemic
to be a bleak financial outlook has been
transformed during the year
by the generosity of central government
support
that kobe's support of course extended
also to our wider community
with 34 million of government grants
being received for onward transmission
to local businesses as set out in table
in paragraph 5.3 some of the government
funding for both
the council and the wider community is
being carried forward
into 2122 for mitigation and recovery
we have experienced reduced council tax
and business rate collection
during 2021 as set out in paragraph 6.4
but this does not affect the year under
review
as the budgeted amounts are guaranteed
by the collection fund
but they will affect this coming year
2122
but we have reserves built up within the
business rates and council tax reserve
to mitigate such an outcome
so turning now to the out-turn position
members should first note that there are
717
000 pounds with expenditure carry
forward requests
as detailed in appendix e and cabinet is
asked to via recommendation 3.3
to approve these after allowing these
carry forwards there is still a surplus
for the year of 911 000.
the variances are set out in detail in
appendix a
with extensive explanation against each
heading
i won't go through those in detail this
large appendix would probably entail in
our presentation
but key highlights are additional
planning income of
231 000 and a saving against budget of
466
000 on planning appeals we have
advantageous interest rates on our
borrowings to finance gateway 14
which saved 259 000 and staffing savings
throughout the organization
of 474 000 as our ability to recruit
vacant positions was impacted during
lockdown
offsetting these was an adverse variance
of 116 000 from cifco
as new investment and hence new rental
generation
was pushed towards the end of the
financial year
so that's just a short overview and of
course we welcome any questions
on detail within the extensive appendix
a
now we're proposing to allocate the 911
000 surplus across four reserve headings
78 000 to waste reserve 86 000 to the
joint local plan reserve
133 000 to the planning legal reserve
and then the balance which is 613 000
to allocate to our growth and efficiency
reserve
we'll then have over 21 million in
general fund earmarked reserves
excluding sill
at the year end which is set out in
detail in appendix d
of course no out turn report will be
complete without also reporting on our
capital expenditure
incurred expenditure of 26.29 million in
the year
with contractual commitments at the year
end of a further 1.294 million
and in addition we are requesting to
carry forward
8.937 million and with 17 various
categories
as set out in paragraph 6 18
now in total latex sees our revised
capital program by over 2 million
as we completed the second tranche of
cifco earlier than anticipated to meet
the public work
loans board requirements going forward
as always before finishing a year's out
turn introduction i want to pay tribute
to all the hard work undertaken by our
finance staff
in this exceptional year it's certainly
not been business as usual
with staff working from home with some
of the finance team
seconded to assist with the distribution
of the various government grants
and with the requirement to pull
together regular covert related detail
returns to central government
throughout the year this of course had
all been done whilst maintaining the
vital day-to-day work
so i'd like to offer the entire finance
team our sincere thanks and appreciation
in closing i'd like now to move the full
recommendations set out
in paragraph three that includes noting
the 911 000 revenue surplus
approving the for transfers to reserves
approving the various revenue carry
forward requests
and lastly approving the various capital
carry forward requests
i'll be happy to answer any questions
members may have on this very detailed
report
but first i'd ask for a second for this
recommendations
thank you madam chairman thank you can i
have a secretary please
councillor gault thank you very much
i'm now going to ask the baby cabinet
member for finance to introduce the baby
report
thank you thank you council morley
i'm pleased to introduce report bca2114
to cabinet
the general fund financial out turn for
2020 to 21
covering the revenue and capital
financial performance for the year
one month after approving the 2020-21
budget
code 19 hit the uk and this has had a
significant impact on the council's
financial position
and over the medium term as well however
due to effective regular monitoring the
government was able to provide
effective and substantial financial
support to local authorities which has
protected us from what could have been a
devastating situation
we had anticipated a significant impact
on the collection of council tax and
business rates
and this was monitored very closely
during the year
a number of government support measures
outlined in paragraph 4.3
meant that our overall income was 284
000 pounds higher than budget
the pandemic also impacted the general
running of the council services and its
ability to recruit staff
so expenditude levels were lower than
anticipated helping us
an overall surplus and the main areas
that contributed to the over
overall position were staffing capital
financing charges
development management and business
rates
in addition several service areas have
requested funds to be carried forward
into 2021 to 22
to enable recovery transformation work
to take place
the three-year comprehensive spending
review was delayed again and a one-year
review was published in november
focusing on prioritizing the response to
covert
the fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset have
also been delayed
in terms of the covered impact an
increasing list of grant schemes and
business rate
reliefs to support businesses affected
by covert 19 were
provided during the year and there were
also the self-isolation scheme to
support
those on the lower income the full end
year
details of money received and paid out
is shown in paragraph 5.3
as i have reported throughout the year
covert has also impacted our finances
we have incurred additional unplanned
costs 988 000 pounds and a loss of
income of six hundred and forty one
thousand pounds
however we have received two point six
million pounds from the government
support
funds and also from the sales fees and
charges compensation
this means that we're able to put eight
hundred ninety one thousand pounds into
the covered reserve
giving an end-of-year reserve balance of
1.171 million pounds
and this together with a further 414 000
pounds of covered funding received in
the current year
will cover our continuing response and
recovery activity
we have also been able to make savings
to everyone working from home
and a reduction in recruitment the full
financial impact
excluding the collection fund is shown
in detail in the table at paragraph 5.10
we still don't know the long-term impact
but we do have a healthy reserve to see
us through the next year
in addition the scheme that covers 75
percent of irrecoverable sales fees and
charges losses above the five percent of
planned income
was extended until the end of june and
so there will be further benefit from
this in the upturn for the current year
looking at the medium term the overall
budget gap for the three years beyond
the current year to 2024 to 25
amounts to a cumulative deficit of 1.7
million pounds although there have been
losses due to covert
the business rates and council tax
income as i said earlier is 284 000
pounds higher than the budget
covered losses in the collection fund
can now be spread over the next three
years and so the bulk of the section 31
grants received for business rate retail
discounts
4.71 sorry 4.7 million of the 4.9
million received
has been added to the business rates and
council tax reserve to cover these
future collection fund losses
overall i'm pleased to report that the
revenue account position for the council
at the end of the year is positive
after proposed carry forwards we have a
surplus of 736
000 pounds for the year which i'm
proposing should be transferred to five
different reserves as shown in the table
in paragraph 6.5
the largest transfers of 373 thousand
pounds
to the transformation fund and 200 000
pounds to the climate change and
biodiversity reserve which we set up in
this year's budget
this is good news and testament to the
prudent management of our finances by
the section 151 officers team
and i think we can all celebrate this
given the difficult year we've had
the key variances compared with budget
are summarized in paragraph 6.5
with the detail provided in appendix a
in summary the outturn surplus is made
up of a 452 000 pounds
favorable variance in the budget
requirement plus the 284 thousand pounds
favourable variance in the funding
we received 4.624 million pounds of sill
income in the year which is up from
2.087 million for the 2019 to 20 budget
apart from the five percent admin charge
this will be transferred to the capital
grants
unapplied account appendix b shows how
we're spending 100
businesses retention pilot funding and
713 000 pounds is still unspent
which 122 000 pounds is as yet
unallocated
i just wish to draw you to your
attention there is actually an error in
that appendix and that the last line
item has not been included in the totals
for that appendix but
this is in the process of being
corrected
paragraph 6.9 of the report summarizes
the movements in the transformation fund
which now has a balance of 1
151 pounds at the end of the year
including commitments
assuming that recommendation 3.2 is
approved
this gives us a sizeable pot to deliver
our ambitions
in the strategic priorities given that
this is the primary purpose of this fund
now
it will be renamed the street the
strategic priorities fund
the details are provided in appendix c
paragraph 6.11 and appendix d show our
general funding amount reserves
including transfers
the end-of-year total shows a balance of
12.657 million pounds
but this does include a carry forward to
2021 to 22
of the business rate six section 31
grants enterprise zone income in the
business rates reserve
after taking this into account there is
a favorable net movement in reserve
levels of 1.713 million pounds
excluding carryforwards and the
transfers proposing this out turn
the carry forwards amounted to 571 000
pounds are listed in appendix e
finally our general fund capital program
is detailed in paragraph 613 to 618 and
appendix f
curved 19 has resulted in a number of
delays and increased costs
the only line item that i think we do
need to discuss today
following the decision at last week's
castle meeting not to make a specific
capital expenditure provision for our
new bellevue park entrance
until the land and house sale is
completed is the four million pound
expenditure for bellevue
this is a carry forward from 2019 to 20
and relates to the former hotel project
capital financing
we are proposing to carry forward 2
million pounds of this to 21
21 to 22 in case it is required
we have a 37.284.284
million revised capital expenditure
program this year
including 17.118 million pounds for
cifco and a total expenditure of 22.879
million pounds
there is an overall adverse variance of
223 000 pounds with the main components
of this being an adverse variance for
cifco
at 2.182 million pounds as a result of
bringing forward the completion of the
investment program
and this is offset by the proposed
reduction of the bellevue carry forward
that i mentioned earlier
contractual commitments of 826 thousand
pounds are listed in paragraph 817
and proposed carryforward requests
totaling 13.802 million pounds are
listed in paragraph 618.
a summary of the variances related to
the carried forwards and underspends
listed in paragraph 6.16
and more details provided in appendix f
finally i'd like to thank our finance
team for all
their continuing hard work keeping up
with the changing covered position
during the past year
as well as their usual activities
activities maintaining budgets and
accounts
a task that is doubled because we are
still two separate councils
before opening up the questions and
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section three of the
report
noting the general fund out turn surplus
of 736 000 pounds
and approving the transfers of this
surplus to earmarked reserves
and the strategic priorities fund and
may i have a second to please
chancellor osborne
thank you thank you chair
thank you council award do we have any
questions from
mid-suffolk members
any questions from baba members
counselor arty
um it's just done with regard to
how the recommendation ties up with the
paper
and um i found
the 373 000 to the transformation fund
and the revenue carry forward of 571
which is referred to
as being in paragraph 612
i've found the capital carry forward of
13.8 million referred to
i mean the recommendations as being in
paragraph 618
but i can't see the transfer to reserves
of 363
000 in the recommendation um
specifically
in paragraph 6.5
it's at the end of paragraph 6.5
is it right i'll just scroll
down
i just
you just bear with me a second
the only reason i'm asking the question
is that of course the recommendation
should tie up with the reference to the
paper
yeah um if you look at
uh the at the end of paragraph 6.5
where it says proposed movements to
variances sorry to reserves
you've got waste planning joint local
plan climate change and biodiversity
and transformation fund you've got 373
for the transformation fund and the
others
they're shown separately for each of
those other four reserves
on page 23 of your report yeah well i'm
looking at it
but nowhere do we actually see the
figure of 363
000 do we if you add up
those numbers you'll get to
um
uh 383 yeah
363 sorry if you add up those numbers
okay
are you happy with that response
counselor
um as long as it does add up yeah i'm
just doing the maths now
lovely thank you i'm now going to open
it up to non-cabinet members
councilory burn
thank you very much chair and um thank
you councillor whitehead for your report
for mid-suffolk
um i've got three questions if i may um
firstly i do think that the funding from
government of 2.6 million should have
been
included at the beginning of the report
against the costs of 1.95 million
um which shows a net position from
central government of six
um over six million i think that should
have been included at the beginning
but with that um funding
um meaning that reserves have been
increased
by three million pounds overall and
there's now
862 000 pounds in the covid mitigation
reserve
um firstly what confidence do you have
that this funding
um will be used in the current financial
year
and what specifically for
um secondly there's the carry forwards
of 717 thousand pounds
um again um could you give me
give us assurances that this won't lead
to further underspends
in the current financial year um given
the very challenging year we've had
um to date third
and then thirdly if i may given that the
majority of the 717
000 is relating to staffing
what progress is there towards being
fully staffed
to undertake work that the council
wasn't able to do in 20 20 21
due to the obvious and clear need for
the focus
on the on the existing covid situation
but i would like some
um to know that that funding will be
spent this year on
staffing as the report says and that
therefore that um
the work for the council will continue
thank you very much chair
so thank you councillor even uh to your
first question
and the the fact that yes the uh
government funding
hasn't all been spent in the last year
and that we have
this eight six to two thousand carry
forward into
covered reserve and you you ask
what use is that going to be for i mean
we keep talking about freedom day and
and getting out of covert but
um this thing just seems to keep
carrying on with extra variants and etc
so
it is vital we do have that reserve i
just can't say
at this point in time exactly what it
will be spent on
um but um i'm sure within
you know our district of 80 000
residents um
it will be um well put
put to good use but if the officer has
any anything extra to
add to that in terms of coverage usage
um
you're happy for catherine to what you
wanted to do
thank you chair if you want me just to
add a bit
to that um we know there will be
continuing issues with some things like
council tax and
business rates we know the furlough
scheme is is ending this year so there
could be further pressures on the
council's finances
that aren't funded from the government
so having some money in reserve brought
forth from last year will
assist us with that um our leisure
provision is another one that's
obviously been been suffering during the
pandemic and
had to be closed so they might have
further pressure during this year as
well
so i think there are a number of areas
that we're likely to need to commit the
reserve towards but i think it's very
difficult at this point in time as
councilor whitehead said
to exactly say how that is going to be
spent
in terms of three questions onto the
second question
which wasn't talking about the 717
000 of carry which is set out in
paragraph 6 12 and also
details in para appendix
e so that all those details there which
i think
basic particular appendix c we can clear
see that the um
you know as part of the year-end close
the
um assistant directors have put a bit of
a lot of effort into determining various
um
carry forwards that they'd want to
request and the reasons for it which are
also
all set out in detail so from that point
of view i think it's been
well thought out and um a coherent plan
for these carry forwards
now of course the question then was if
we have these carry forwards will that
lead to underspends elsewhere
um i mean um we do try and bring in our
budgets bringing our actuals below
budget anyway
but it's far too early in this in the
year i think to sort of
start to get into that kind of detail
and again just carefully want to add
anything to
that comment
thank you councillor whitehead um just
to say one or two of the items that are
sort of contained within appendix e
do span more than one financial year so
there will be some things that will be
unspent as at the end of this current
financial year
just a couple of examples in there under
the development management heading
there's a two year fixed term project
supports obviously that some of that
will need to be carried forward
and the largest item on there is is the
ict
which is you know supporting our digital
and our customer transformation program
again some of that is staffing that's
going to be for more than one year so
there will be some elements of that that
will be unspent at the year end
and then just turn into the third
question councilory burn had in terms of
staffing obviously as i said in my intro
uh during lockdown
it basically recruit was suspended and
yet
beyond that um a great deal has been put
into
recruiting and i'd be happy though if um
our ceo has had a pace always wanted to
make any comment on staffing
thank you councilwriter i predicted you
might look in my direction which is fine
um yes in terms of staffing members will
have seen
more recently uh through their most
recent update that i'd provided
about a month or so ago full picture in
relation to staffing
and although we had an initial impact
during the first lockdown in terms of
the ability to recruit
since then i think pretty much that all
the hr team have been doing is
recruiting people
and you'll see that in the weekly
adverts that go out through working
together for example
you'll see the number of vacancies and
and natural turnover as well
so we have more staff than we ever have
had in the last four years
uh which is a good thing uh in terms of
head count
and in terms of full-time equivalent
staffing but it's a constant
challenge not least as many people have
decided to make personal decisions about
where they want to work how often they
want to work
where in the world they want to work but
by virtue of the pandemic
and so i don't think that's going to be
something that's simply resolved as we
hopefully come out of the pandemic i
think that will continue to be
a challenge for us and we'll make sure
that we've got the staff that we need to
do the jobs that you want us to do
thank you councillor
yes one of them does work sorry about
that on page 39 i'm looking at
capital program general fund leisure
contracts
uh and the same applies one or two other
places but i'll concentrate just on
those
those lines there and in particular
funds were carried forward from previous
year to last year
and they weren't spent a review has been
undertaken
what is the likelihood i mean i don't
understand exactly what it is that needs
to be done to improve the two leisure
centers
um but what's the likelihood that that
work will actually be done
in the current financial year
i i don't have that immediate to hand
but
if um then if catherine does either or
not
i'm afraid i don't have that level of
detail with me here but
we can go away and ask the relevant
assistant director and come back with an
answer to that question
councillor plattman do you want to come
in on this
yes um the you're talking about the
improvements to the leisure centers
yeah the question that there are there
is several lines in there
there's the refurbishment which appears
to
be more or less complete but there's
also the improvements which are separate
and it says their stone market leisure
center project will be completed in 2122
that's the refurbishment
but but monies were carried over from
the previous year to last year
and weren't spent last year on the
improvements
are there are there improvements that
still need to be carried out
and if so will they be carried out as
far as i know
um stradbroke has been improved
with a new gym new gym equipment um
changing rooms etc etc a refurb
and the stone market leisure center we
all went and opened well flew over spent
and opened that the other day and it's
absolutely amazing
i think there may be some more um
smaller improvements around the pool
but everything's in operational order at
the moment
if anybody else knows anything else
please do say
council whitehead yes councilwoman when
looking at the table it does seem a very
valid question to ask and say we don't
have the details immediately but we'll
give you a detailed response to that
outside the meeting
my understanding was that the
refurbishment was
related to the equipment and the
improvements related to the structure of
the
of the building in order to accommodate
the new equipment
but as council whitehead says we'll
clarify that outside this meeting
yeah that's fine thank you
does anybody else have any questions
so i'll now open up the item for debate
oh sorry council busby that's okay
can't look everywhere just a general
question did we furlough
any of our staff
i suspect that's one for me no we didn't
just looking at the things like the
waste that brings sites trade waste etc
i remember there were periods where
waste wasn't being collected
and the truck the bring sites were
closed
what were the uh the people that were
employed there
doing or how were they funded
so we did have a period of time where we
didn't have the brown bean collection
service operating and that was because
of the reduction in number of staff
due to ill health and so the staff
weren't there to be able to run the
service otherwise we would have been
continuing to run service
in terms of the bring sites are you
referring to bring sites in terms of the
household waste recycling sites
so they're run by the county council
that's not what i thought but so why do
we have them um
appearing in our uh expensive variants
then as a
as an adverse variance uh it says
fluctuation in glass
disposal costs and the reduction in
paper collections have
increased disposal costs above budget
the two elements then to the bring sites
one the running of it and
the other the uh handling of the actual
waste
i'm going to cheat and look at council
arthur who looks who looks deep in
thought but but
i know knows much more about waste than
i do
okay i'm not quite sure about the
question but
brings sites remained open
throughout the coverage restrictions
um that there has been a change with
regard to the amount that's collected
and therefore the amount that's returned
to us
by the contractor but that's just an
ordinary
annual variance as you probably know
there's also
an issue now with regard to the value of
paper
and the value of paper that has been
collected through paper banks
but i think the general answer to your
question is that all of the bring sites
have remained open
and the household waste and recycling
centres are not a cost to us
at all that's the suffolk county council
cost does that
answer your question
well i think it kind of says that yes
the operation of the science of county
council
but the the dealing with the actual
waste that comes into those sites is
down to us
is that right well how can we have a
variance in that case
because of the cost of dealing with the
glass and the paper
you're getting confused the it's the
glass and the paper through
bring sites so that's the paper banks
and
the glass banks okay it's nothing to do
with the household waste and recycling
centre or
waste through the murf because we don't
collect glass
through the nerf thank you
it must be nice to be an expert in waste
thank you
thank you so we're moving into debate
now
does anybody wish to open the debate
so i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to
conduct the vote we'll take the
mid-suffolk vote
first that's okay
chair i think we can actually do them
simultaneously
sorry we can do the about simultaneously
or simultaneously
okay that's fine
members your the vote is now in progress
on your modern.gov app
so
sorry my um my thing is still saying not
started i can see that it obviously has
but i don't know if mine
isn't refreshing or i've lost the wi-fi
or what
okay i'll ask the governance officer to
take your vote manually
is anybody else having trouble
counseling him may i have your vote oh
yes four thank you
councillor morley that is uh nine votes
for and that's unanimous for
mid-suffolk
and for the paper boat
i just want mom and chair
chair that is six votes for for uh baber
okay thank you
item nine is mca 21-40
and bca 2115
and this is the housing revenue account
financial out turn
for 2020-21 and i'm going to invite the
mid-south
cabinet member for finance to introduce
the mid-suffolk report first thank you
thank you madam chairman i'm pleased now
to introduce a second outdoor report of
the day
mca 2114 to cover the outcome for the
2021
of our ring fenced housing revenue
account so this account covers the
council's
housing stock over 3 000 dwellings along
with associated garages and land
holdings
in the year under review we have
budgeted an in-year deficit
of 564 000 but the out turn is in fact a
surplus of 523
000 so a positive turnaround of over 1
million pounds
the analysis behind this turnaround is
set out in the report commencing with
the table in paragraph 6.5
and with detailed explanations of the
various income and expenditure headings
given in the report in paragraph 6.7
through to 6.12. now as the detail is
set out there i don't intend to go
through them all in this introduction
but of course we'll be happy to answer
any questions that might arise from
those explanations
it is worth noting though that though
that there has been minimum
impact on rental income collection and
we anticipate little if any bad debt
as we are dealing with long-term secure
tendencies
the key driver of this year's positive
variance though is the heading
revenue contribution to capital with a
positive variance of 1.383 million
so i feel i should say a little bit more
about that within this introduction
the kobit 19 global pandemic affected
both the day-to-day operations of the
housing team
and also impacted the new build
programme
with budget income being higher than
budgeted ongoing expenditure
we had a plan to use 2.604 million
of our revenue to fund the new build
program
however with development grinding to a
halt during last year's lockdown
followed only by a slow recovery that
wasn't the scope to achieve the full
new build program last year so only 1.2
to 1 million of the budgeted revenue
contribution to capital
has been utilized during 2021 and hence
the large positive variance
this report also looks at the capital
programme and details that are set out
in the table within paragraph 616
and in appendix a we spent 11.147
million of this capital program
we've contracted for a further 6.23
million
and our cabinet today is requested to
carry forward a further 7.391 million
as set out in paragraph 619.
now this report is financially
orientated by its very nature
but i'd like to take the opportunity to
acknowledge the excellent work and
dedication of the housing team
during the very unusual and difficult
circumstances posed by the coven 19
pandemic
there is a much bigger picture here in
terms of tenant support
and the housing team going the extra
mile that any financial report can paint
but i know the cabinet and i'm sure the
wider council of cohort
do truly appreciate their great work
i think that covers all i want to say in
my introduction i'd like to move the
three recommendations set out in
section three and as i said earlier
we're happy to take any questions
members may have
but first i'll invite the cabinet member
for housing to second those
recommendations
thank you
can i have a seconder please counselor
heading thank you very much
i'm now going to invite the cabinet
member for finance
for baber to introduce the baby report
thank you
thank you i'm pleased to introduce
report bca2115 to cabinet
the housing revenue account turned for
2020 to 21
including both the hra revenue budget
and the capital program
as we're all aware curved has had a
financial impact on the hra throughout
2020 to 21
rent levels have been at risk repairs
and maintenance were reduced to
emergency repairs for existing tenants
only
and to complete void work in order to
support the accommodation of the
homeless and rough sleepers
the new build program also came to
standstill in the first lockdown
and new building repairs and maintenance
did restart after the autumn lockdown
albeit within curved safety guidelines
but then we're impacted by the second
lockdown in january
our service levels were still will still
take time to recover
and there will be a backlog of work
there are now additional costs and
carrying out new build work safely
as the year has progressed the financial
impact has been forecast with more
certainty
and the current impact assessment is
presented in section 5 of the report
the additional costs due to curvature
mainly the need for ppe
amounting to 47 000 pounds which has
been transferred from the government
support grants money
we have seen a minimal impact on rent
levels this year
however and rents are expected to be
reclaimed eventually rather than written
off but this will extend beyond the
current financial year
as a result of the extension to the
furlough scheme we have not seen any
reduction to income levels this year
instead the impact could extend into the
current year of tenants in employment
are impacted when furlough ends
at the end of next month
the revenue position is detailed in
paragraph 6.4 to 6.12.
and as always the financial position of
the hra should be viewed in the context
of the updated 30-year business plan
the budget set in february last year
showed a forecast surplus position for
2020 to 21
of 334 000 pounds the final position
is a surplus of 2.941 million pounds
which represents a favorable variance of
2.607 million pounds
the table in paragraph 6.5 lists the
main items that
uh in the budget and also detailed
breakdown of the variances
is provided in paragraph 6.6 to 6.12
there there are many expenditure items
that are under spends due to covert and
these will be deferred to next year but
i
just want to draw your attention to the
principal items
that contribute to the favorable
variants
and that is building services are now
showing an adverse variance of one point
eight six thousand uh sorry 186 000
pounds
due to an overspend on subcontractors
used to complete outstanding jobs
relating from services
service suspension during the lockdowns
there is also an adverse variance of
one point just over a million 1.003
million pounds of depreciation due to an
increase in hra
dwelling values for the 2019 to 20
accounts
which was completed after the budget was
finalized
this hasn't been previously reported in
quarters earlier in the year
there is a favorable variance of the
full amount of the revenue contribution
to capital of
2.875 million pounds because of slippage
in the capital program
and this is a significant uh increase in
that since
uh the last time this was reported so
all this means that our hra balances are
forecast to be 16.896 million pounds
as detailed in paragraph 6.12. the
earmarked reserves are shown in appendix
b
with the budget surplus added to the
strategic priorities reserved
as reported throughout the year curves
has had a huge impact on our capital
program
and on the normally difficult task of
accurately assessing the level of
payments complex capital schemes
the capital program is itemized
independence a and further detail
provided paragraph 613 to 618 of the
report
actual capital expenditure for the year
totals 12.602 million pounds
against a budget of 28.824 million
pounds
although they have restarted projects
have fallen behind schedule and their
budgets will be carried forward to meet
expenditure incurred next year
there are contractual commitments of
5.422 million pounds listed in table 617
and carry forward requests of 10.323
million pounds
listed in 618. there is overall
sick 476 000 pound favorable variance in
the capital program
finally i'd like to take thank our
finance and housing teams for preparing
the south turn
and also the housing team for all their
hard work in trying to maintain a
repairs and maintenance program in the
face of so many difficulties this year
and before opening up for questions and
debate i'd first like to move the
recommendations in section 3 of
the report noting council's out turn for
the hra
and improving the revenue transfer
requests and capital carry forward
requests
may i ask the cabinet member for housing
to second please
cancel osborne thank you very much
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
counselor arthur yeah i've got a
question
about paragraphs 5.2
and 6.6 which
both talk about the same thing
which is a favorable variance
as a result of dwelling rents
and the explanation in 6.6 is
that the favorable variance is as a
result of the
income budget being set too low
and the question is really probably for
um gavin and that is
why was the budget set too low was it
um because we had new houses coming on
stream that um
came came in earlier than we thought so
we had rents from those
was it a lower level of sales so
we didn't lose as much rent from
those houses as we thought we would or
is it that we made an assumption
that there would be unpaid rent which
didn't materialize
or is it a combination of all the above
gavin perhaps you can help us with this
thank you chair and uh thank you uh
member for the question
um it's an honest answer and it's a
straightforward answer uh the answer is
that
in regards to the previous year the
rents have been set too low so
this was an amendment uh and reflection
of that so
any more questions
cancer busby yeah we have uh favorable
variances and we have adverse variances
perhaps built to have
perverse variances if we look at 6.9
depreciation an adverse variance of 1
1 million pounds which is due to an
increase
in the values of the buildings
so we're showing a million pounds
adverse variance because the
the value of our properties have gone up
but i don't see where we take the credit
for the
increase in value
uh catherine can you help us
thank you chair um we have to get the
properties valued each year as part of
our statement of accounts
and and this is a difference between how
we have to account for the housing
revenue account compared to
the general fund because depreciation
for housing
does actually impact into the revenue
account
it's a it's a real charge if you like so
that has a direct
impact and as you see this year the
increased valuation has increased the
depreciation because we have to allow
for a certain level of depreciation
whereas on the general fund side
that's all handled below the line and it
doesn't actually
impact so i say what you're seeing here
is a difference between the accounting
treatment that we have to follow between
the between the two accounts but do we
not
where do we show the the increasing
value of the properties then where does
that come through
that would be shown in the balance sheet
thank you any more questions
councillor welland thank you chad
um my questions are around the
new build program including acquisitions
and i'm just interested to know how the
breakdown of the
um the money that was spent whether
the majority of it was actually in the
bill the new build or whether
it was um a lot of acquisitions because
we've got some
we're carrying quite a lot of money
forward
so one of the questions is around um
is that the the new build program
including acquisitions which seems to be
uncommitted to anything in particular 5
million
is that is that expected to be new
contracts that haven't been
let yet is it in purchasing land or is
it
actually purchasing houses for council
rent
that's the first question and the second
question is around the planned
maintenance
um this i think there's 2.093 this is in
619 which is planned maintenance that
isn't committed so is it
is it actually planned maintenance it
um or um or is it just some money that's
going to be spent
on maintenance that isn't yet
planned uh but is in line with what on
what we normally do
in terms of maintaining our council
houses
and the third question is if we are
underspent by so much
uh as the condition of our properties
um are they are they deteriorating
should we be spending this money
and quickly in order to bring them up to
scratch
thank you thank you chair and uh thank
you councilwell for the questions
um i don't have the the numbers in
relation to the the number of new builds
and acquisitions going forward
my expectation is it would be uh new
build
um and i know from a conversation on
friday with officers in the team
across the two councils we're expecting
to deliver more than 270 new homes
over the next 18 months so there is
quite a significant amount of new build
development coming forward
as a result of delays over the past 12
months or more
in relation to the question in relation
to planned maintenance that is
planned maintenance so we have
within our stock profile an expectation
that we will improve homes on a regular
basis
um that's planned in terms of uh whether
it be a new roof
every 50 years a new bathroom every 25
years
so on and so forth so um that that
planned expenditure will we'll need to
play catch up on
in terms of of contracts and we're
actually doing quite significant amount
of work in
in terms of procurement of our capital
spend
and as part of that we're using
procurement frameworks and we're also
looking at
up to five year plus contracts uh to
to to maximize that expenditure um you
raise a really valid point um and
it would be accepted that um the less we
spend on our homes
than naturally they're going to fall
into more disrepair
so it's important that we spend that
money we spend it
in a timely fashion but i'd also want to
make sure that we're
we're spending it on quality and
ensuring that we are improving the homes
not just for now but but in the long
term so
for example we have uh stock condition
surveyors that their sold job is
visiting our stock and inspecting it and
we've inspected
now um more than 70 of our total stock
and our plan is to inspect every home
every five years
uh to give us that planned and capital
program in terms of
of understanding what we need to spend
because naturally we're not going to
just
uh replace component parts if they're if
they've not been exhausted or don't need
updating so that work continues so
hopefully that that is some
some reassurance obviously as we develop
the hra business plan
um obviously we've got uh that the
priorities around
uh retrofit and sustainability as well
and i'd expect to see more and more
coming forward over the next 12 to 18
months in terms of programmes
to support those endeavors in the same
way we've attracted additional
grant funding to support some of those
endeavors as well
thank you so we can now move into debate
does anybody want to start us off
okay in which case i'm going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress for
both cabinets
apologies chair my laptop has decided to
update itself so could i give my vote
verbally if that's okay in which case
i'm voting for the recommendations
thank you
chair that is uh nine votes four and
that's unanimous
for mid-suffolk
and it's six votes for four vapor
cabinets that's unanimous too
thank you very much item 10
is mca 21-15
and bca 21-16 and this is the creation
of a parking strategy for baber and
mid-suffolk district council
maybe have a short break to change your
offices please i do apologize
you're quite right of course we're just
going to have a quick pause
for the desks to be cleared thank you
thank you everybody we're back to item
10. this is mca
21-15 and bca
21-16 the creation of a parking strategy
for baber and mid suffolk district
councils
i'm going to ask the mitsuba cabinet
member for the environment to introduce
the mid-suffolk report
thank you thank you very much
madam chairman i'm very pleased to
introduce
this parking strategy report
mca forward slash 21 forward slash 15.
the purpose of this report is to
introduce the process
for developing a parking strategy
suitable for common application
across mid-suffolk and baylor district
councils
it will in practice of course reflect
their differences
the report also seeks approval for the
funds
to initialize the work
both baber and midsuffer councils need
to develop a strategy that sets out the
mid to long-term approach to vehicular
parking
across the districts the strategy
at a high level needs to identify
parking demand and supply
within the relevant district council
areas for the next five to ten years
it needs to reflect national guidance as
it applies to both future
town center evolution and commuting
patterns
and reflect the changing needs of
transport insofar as this is possible
it needs to anticipate the patterns of
demand and be capable of adaptation
a key function of the strategy will be
to enable
suitable levels of car and other types
of vehicle
to park in town centers
to help support town centre regeneration
both commercial and residential and to
enable
access to terms as well as rural
villages
to do this usefully the strategy must
take into account
all forms of parking public and private
public transport and transport trends
it is important to ensure that shoppers
tourists visitors residents workers and
commuters
have access to sufficient safe easy to
use parking
but suitable hours of the day or night
i would like to note that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee
has reviewed this draft strategy at its
june meeting and its recommendations are
and will be taken
into account as the process develops
the districts need the help of a
specialist consultant to prepare the
strategy
as there is too much detailed work
involved for this to be prepared
in-house
and this would end up costing more and
taking more time
the initial groundwork for the strategy
will require extensive data gathering
and close cooperation with other local
authorities
including particularly the county
council as well as external stakeholders
and all providers of vehicle parking
both on and off street
in urban areas or elsewhere
work on the parking strategy is
estimated to cost approximately 41 000
pounds
of which mid-suffolk's share is twenty
thousand
five hundred pounds to be taken from the
growth and efficiency fund
earmarked reserved the districts have
agreed to secure the services
of 2020 consultancy solutions
limited to undertake the work
cabinet is therefore asked to agree that
funds be allocated
so that the consultants can commence
i would like to emphasize that this will
be a process with many opportunities for
member and stakeholder input along the
way
and that the process is at inception
stage
and it will develop alongside the ideas
and views of those standing to benefit
from it
i would also like to note that in
paragraph 4.7 in your report
where the schedule for the various
stages
is set out that there are a couple of
very minor corrections to dates
that stage one will be completed
target date of 8th of october not the
end of september
and that stage 2 will be completed by
the 31st of may not the 30th april
2022 so um i
seek approval for the recommendations in
this report thank you
thank you councillor fleming can i have
a second to please thank you councillor
richardson
and i now invite the baby cabinet member
for the environment to introduce the
baby report
thank you very much madam chairman
earlier this year the council and the
general public thanks to media gossip
recognize the need for a parking
strategy which is why i'm presenting
report bca forward slash 21 forward
16 here today its purpose is to start
the formulation of that very strategy
both baber and mid-suffolk district
councils are keen to develop a parking
strategy
that provides a comprehensive route map
with regard to the long-term approach to
the provision of parking across the
district
the strategy at a high level needs to
identify
our parking requirements for the next
five years
to reflect national policy guidance as
it applies to both the future of town
centres
and high streets to recognize the need
for sustainable transport and travel
as well as patterns of demand the skills
and services of consultants who are
specialists
in this area ensuring the right level
and types of car parking facilities
with the right controls in place for
their use will help to support
regeneration and enable development
in and around the district's town
centers
as well as in rural villages
it is important to ensure that shoppers
tourists visitors
residents workers and commuters
have access to sufficient good quality
safe welcoming parking opportunities
more specifically the parking strategy
needs to provide a set of detailed
recommendations
as to the nature of future parking
provision
serving both town centres and rural
villages
and how they will function operationally
many of you will say but we know we
haven't got enough spaces
we need to do this oh no no we need to
do that
but as a council we need to gather data
we need to analyze this data in order to
formulate a policy
and the policy cannot be formulated
without first
having a strategy the strategy will be
the same across the two districts but
the detail within it will most
definitely reflect
our differences we need to produce a
document that builds
on our combined needs so that we do not
keep having to reinvent the wheel i'm
asking cabinet to agree that we should
commence work on the formulation of
baber's first parking strategy
alongside mid-suffolk and for approval
to contribute
twenty thousand five hundred pounds from
the transformation fund
earmarked reserve to start this very
necessary piece of work
thank you very much madam chairman thank
you councilman lvc
do we have a second for baber
councillor osborne thank you
do we have any questions from cabinet
members counselor arthi
yeah i've got a question and it's about
um
stage one and stage two um
i appreciate that we're going to have
our input
um later but stage one
as councillor malvizi said is all about
gathering
the data which is really important and i
notice in stage two we get mention of ev
charges i think it's incredibly
important at stage one to actually
gather the evidence
about ev charges that we have installed
we need to know what the usage trends
are
so that's the number of visits the
length of charge
the rate of increase of usage of the
car charger points and if we can get the
information it would actually be quite
useful to know how much energy has
actually been dispensed in a charge
because we need to look at whether the
whether the charges that we've got
are powerful enough because there seems
to be a trend towards higher and higher
capacity charges
for electric vehicles so i'd just like
to be absolutely sure that stage one
will
include data gathering on our ev
charger points
councillor davis yeah thank you um
my question is and i appreciate um
apologies cancer davis i thought you
were going to attempt to answer
counselor arthur's question
i know i thought you were inviting me to
ask a question
can i ask the associate director to um
respond to councillor arthi
and good morning thank you everybody
thanks for the question so
absolutely that evidence will be and
that data will be part of stage one
stage two is very much looking back at
that data and looking back at that
evidence and formulating some
recommendations that we would then
consult on so
um the within the paper i can see how it
might come across
it's about ev charging in stage two but
actually it's an example of the kind of
things that might come out of
the data and the evidence so absolutely
that that will be included in stage one
i just come back on that that's that's
provided that information is available
and it is is it yes that's correct so
we'll have usage data
how frequency and length of time that
people say out of charges
um and we will be doing uh face-to-face
consultations within car parks as well
so through that we can look at types of
vehicles so whether they can actually
take the fast charging or the the
superfast charging as well
thank you councillor davies yeah thank
you
my question is why do we actually need
this strategy
at all and why are we going to be
spending for baby twenty thousand pounds
i appreciate what counselor mal vasey
said in her introduction
but as she pointed out we already have a
national policy we already have national
guidance
um and surely it's down to each
individual towns
um and it is the towns isn't it sudbury
and and hadley really
um that need these well they're parking
to be looked at
we already decide how much we're going
to charge the car parking charges
um suffolk county council decide a lot
on the
the various parking the yellow lines are
not decided by us
so why are we spending twenty thousand
pound on consultants to tell us
probably what we already know or what
the towns can
um manipulate for themselves
councilman thank you madam chairman if i
can reply to councillor davis in the
first instance and then
revert to the ad why do we need the data
because
the car parks are owned by baber
they're not owned by sudbury or hadley
um we may have
we may have sufficient parking spaces
within those car parks we may not
um those car parks were paid out in
other words
they were marked out in bays of several
years ago
they need to be upgraded so we need to
have
valid data upon which to make
a value judgment director
thank you so so just to add to that i
think uh the purpose of this strategy
really is
a commitment to our districts to our
residents and our businesses to say what
where where where we are what what our
land in the sand is and what we think
about parking
both off street and on street and
councilor malfoy is absolutely right and
that on street isn't within
our gift it's it's suffolk county
councils however
a car user doesn't care which council is
is
responsible for it they want to be able
to drive safely
and park safely so the point of this
strategy is to align ourselves with
suffolk to make sure
we're looking at what's going on in our
districts in the next five years
looking at growth looking at what the
need is and using data to provide that
at the moment we could make some some
assumptions and i think we could make
some pretty good ones in some areas
and in other areas we just simply don't
have the data to make those kind of
assumptions and we could therefore be
be making the wrong thing so what i want
to be able to do with this
is both uh give the districts the
uh the assurance i guess to make some
decisions on where we might need some
investment
and then also provide the evidence to
suffolk county council in terms of
highways and what our needs are for the
district
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you madam chairman um i do
actually welcome this review this this
revised strategy
um i think we do have a huge car parking
problem
not only in sudbury and hadley hadley
but as some of our other councillors
will know in our rural areas as well so
i do welcome this but
i'll join in the debate on that one when
we get to it um i see the scope is
outlined in stage one and stage two on
page 57 of the report
i'm really pleased to see that it refers
to
residents permits i hope that refers to
on-street parking permits and i
i would like to see that progressed
outside the timeline of the strategy
itself because
i think our residents are telling us
they want residents parking permits
so i think it would be good to bring
that forward my question to you is and
at the risk of sounding like an old
record
i can't see anything in this scope where
we're going to be looking at
the problems that we have in both
districts on parking on our green
verges and our green areas we're losing
a lot of green space especially in the
winter months when cars are parking on
there and it just turns into a mud bank
and i find it very distressing to see
and i appreciate that we may need to
lose some of those green spaces
and make them actually park in bays but
let's do it in a proper organized way so
that we
start to protect our green and open
spaces
so can i have some reassurance please
that that is actually going to happen
because it's not within the
scope as it currently stands within this
report
thank you very much for the question so
the short answer is
absolutely i can give you that
reassurance the slightly longer answer
is that um
stage one what we've tried to do here is
try and give you some really high level
um elements that are going to be covered
in stage one uh the element that talks
about pre-consultation and key
stakeholder engagement is almost an
open consultation prior to getting into
the detail
so that is the opportunity for people to
talk to us about what's going on where
they live
issues they're having what they like
what they don't like so that is a very
open consultation where we will be
gathering that real
specific information from people and
you'll see there's a list of
stakeholders in the report they're not
exhaustive but
there's a significant amount in there so
hopefully we'll get
everything from um i've got nowhere to
park when everyone's working from home
there's you know verges that people are
parking on that are getting destroyed
right through to we've got community
groups that use our car parks that
um that need some support so absolutely
that's where all of those detailed
pieces of information will come thank
you
thank you any more questions from
cabinet members
councillor busby in theory we're not
supposed to be making
profits out of car parking fees um
should this cert cost of this survey not
be charged
to the parking revenue account rather
than
transformation fund
i'll attempt to answer that um as my uh
finance cabinet members are smiling at
me
so um they absolutely could be
charged to the parking revenue account i
think in um
in baber's situation we know that that
is heavily subsidised so
the the amount that we have an income
doesn't cover the cost of the the
parking function
um however that is that is absolutely um
an option for you however i think i've
suggested in the report what i believe
to be the best option for the funding
okay i hardly consider it to be
transformational
but um and in the
interim are we going to be adopting the
uh
community secretary robert generic's a
proposal that we
offer free car parking in the summer for
shoppers
even as little as 10 minutes
because this is going to solve all of
our high street problems apparently
i don't really think that's relevant to
this paper at this time thank you
it's a strategy it's not ours it's not
what's on the table any more questions
from cabinet members
councillor whitehead thank you it's sort
of
maybe a part question part debate but
we're talking about
very much looking for data and doing a
strategy based on data and my concern is
that
you know if we look back over day for
the last two or three years we have the
issue with ticket machines that weren't
working so
is this a question well yeah it's a
question of how how it might sort of
you you use the data and the dangers
from that data because there's to say
there's
times when the ticket machines weren't
working then we've got the lock downs
and we've got to think about what the
new normals are like um
then we're finding people are doing
staycations rather than going abroad so
tourists place to be busier even
questions i think is to
people be even starting to think about
their own car ownership if they're doing
lower mileage and things
so i suppose my question is how how can
we rely on data when there's so many
ponderables there
yes thank you i think i'd agree you know
this is a real
interesting point in time where we're
coming out of
hopefully coming out the end of the
pandemic we're certainly seeing things
open up again
um i would say every council would
suffer with some kind of ticket machine
issue
and what we can do is look at um across
a piece so in that the average of what
we've got so we've got a number of years
worth of data that we can use
and then i think we have to make some
assumptions around what we think is
going to happen with parking
particularly around our car parks
some of that is going to be through
face-to-face consultation in the car
parks talking to the drivers themselves
so
for instance if i were in that car park
they'd learn that we've dropped to one
car we don't need two anymore my working
from home means that i can use public
transport far more easily to get about
um and so i think some of that that
narrative will come out through those
face-to-face consultations in terms of
what people's
preferences and and the opportunities
that they might be taking up
so i don't think we'll get specific real
scientific data on some stuff but what
we will get some real good qualitative
data thank you
if i can remind you everybody that
questions must relate to the paper
and normally should start with what when
where why or how
i don't want lots of long preambles
before you actually get to your question
so we're now going to move into debate
oh sorry my apologies
non-cabinet member questions counselor
thank you chair um right i'm going to
refer to page
53 so the question is relevant to the
paper
and stage two we were told
would now be reached at the end of may
when overview and scrutiny considered
the the time scale they considered that
report to cabinet which is the last
action on there
should be reached by june 2022
we know it now appears to have slipped
even from september 2022
so i mean is is that a fact that
if if the date for the draft strategy
has slipped have other dates slipped and
if that is the case
when will we have the the policy which
was going to come
out of the out of the uh strategy
because uh councillor malweezy said
there's an urgent need for this
well we could we could be something like
two years away from actually having the
policy
so can we have so can we have some firm
dates around that
the second question is um
around um residence parking and
residence parking schemes which are
referred to
is there a real commitment to consider
residents parking schemes
and they could be paid for schemes
because
overview and scrutiny consider these
were key to the strategy
so i'm i saw nod so uh
they they i see that they will be they
will be considered
um and uh residence parking
there is there is indiscriminate parking
in housing estates
um for all sorts of reasons um
is that going to be looked at people
parking people park in front of
residents homes rather than parking the
car park because it's
cheaper or it's a shorter distance so
will
this indiscriminate parking residential
areas be looked at
and the other question is around
encouraging cycling and walking and the
use of public transport
there's a lot that can be done by the
way that
car parks are laid out and the links
between the car parks and the town
centers and so on
so is there a firm commitment to ensure
that
this strategy will encourage active
transport
thank you councillor fleming
well thank you um i knew i'd get a tough
one
um let me take those in turn
um the dates
i think um there's probably some scope
for flexibility
in the dates i mean i'm looking at stage
two
which is the further consultation with
key stakeholders
which will run from september to march
22
and i'm just thinking that that's a long
time
and i would guess that probably there's
quite a bit of scope there to speed that
process up
and i would hope there is because i i
think that
um it's it's a little bit
disproportionate possibly i'm not sure
quite what we've got in mind to do there
but
um so hopefully
that september 22 date might be able to
be
speeded up a bit no guarantees although
i would refer to
rad to to comment on that
residence parking and the indiscriminate
parking in residence areas i assume you
mean
that possibly commuters park their cars
in residence
areas sometimes or do you mean that
residents
park indiscriminately when they have
visitors i mean what it
looks like is there probably is not
enough
parking in residence areas to serve the
needs of residents
when it comes to the fact that like it
or not
some houses have several cars and
residents do have visitors i think
one thing that this strategy may help us
do
is to identify essential infrastructure
which
is needed as part of housing
developments
and if we have to use this as a tool
then we can
um help to obtain
better parking provision in future
planning
permissions and you know essentially
follow a
developer pays process to improve that
situation obviously that is a long
term strategy but i do feel that
we see so many developments coming
forward with houses crammed in
and quite honestly not enough space for
parking of any kind
um even small vehicles let alone large
ones which unfortunately seem to be the
trend these days
so i see this strategy as being an
essential tool
to obtain more money um to try to
correct this
um let's see what was the third question
now i've
forgotten what that is um
about the the way that you will ensure
that the strategy will encourage
cycling walking and the use of public
transport
right well i think we are committed to
um
taking into account the results of the
um task and finish work that will be
going on
in for the local cycling and walking
policies that are being developed i
think there's a lot of work going on at
county level as well
and i'm confident that
that sustainable transport will be a
really important feature of this
it's got to be as well as parking around
stations and encouraging
modal shifts in all kinds of ways
buses however bus transport evolves i
think this
strategy comes at a time when the whole
matter of um
transport is evolving very quickly and
therefore it needs to be very adaptable
strategy going forward
would you like to add um cass
i think you've covered it nicely there
councillor fleming but but yes just to
say that there's
lots of going work going on around
sustainable travel at the moment
our consultants have got a conversation
in not just with other stakeholders but
particularly with catherine in the team
and obviously the the task force is
there the task of finnish group is there
to talk to as well
but absolutely i think when i spoke
about it being on street not just off
street
it's for exactly the reasons that you're
saying you know our residents and
and businesses don't care whose
responsibility
what is they just want a solution to the
problem
and that often is going to have to be a
joint one between um
suffolk and ourselves so all of those
things around parking availability and
discriminate parking parking across
driveways that kind of thing
they're the things that we want to pick
up on
council mclaren thank you chair um
i think the overview and scrutiny
committee
did a good job in
proposing uh some of these changes but i
i wondered why the grass verges i feel
strongly about grass verges
were omitted from this particular paper
uh councillor osborne did mention them
but
in shockley peninsula for instance
grass verges are the most popular way of
parking
how are you going to sort of
assess that so that's the first question
the second question is around grass
verges and planning committees
grass verges have come up quite
frequently in recent planning committee
meetings
where how are you going to engage
perhaps with
planning committees not just the
planning department but planning
committees
as we make decisions about garage spaces
and things like that
and the last question which
i you and i have had this discussion
before
is how we influence motorist behavior
counselor welum and i have don't agree
on this
but given the behavior that we see
on chocolate peninsula i wondered what
efforts you were going to make
to try and influence to change motors
but
at the moment it is out of hand so that
that's my last question thank you
andrew thank you jen
thank you very much councillor mclaren
so um in terms of the
the first question do we
the report has got well parking itself
is is just
a a menu full of individual specific
issues that that people face grass verge
is absolutely being one of them
so as i mentioned this report looks
quite high level
but please be assured we will be getting
into the nitty-gritty of all of those
specific issues that
the residents parishes towns are facing
grass verge is absolutely being one of
them so within
that pre-consultation hopefully we'll be
getting some of that information
and but also that data gathering piece
is about
what is physically happening where there
are no traffic regulation orders so
where have we got traffic regulation
orders
that people aren't observing and could
be enforced
where if we've got traffic regulation
orders where they they aren't fit for
purpose
and where have we got nothing where we
need something so i think those two
combined things the
the narrative that people will give us
and then that
evidence-based look at what the picture
is
we'll show where we need to do something
and where we need to come in
so i think that that starts answering
your final question as well
which is about having the right the
right structure in place to try and
influence drivers so
if that is i know particularly in short
flight peninsula as you said we've
spoken about this people
parking completely inappropriately and
we need to look at what
what is available to us in terms of
traffic regulation orders
but equally what adequate parking looks
like in shortly you know it's a
it's a tourist venue isn't it people go
there because it's beautiful and they
want to spend time there
and what we're asking is when you're
there to park appropriately and to
behave appropriately
so i think we need to look at what what
the demand is where the opportunities
are
and then in terms of the highway look at
what enforcement is available to us
that's appropriate
thank you okay
thank you councilman thank you chair
um welcome the development of this
strategy but i have a couple of
questions i had three but i think
um keith's asked one of them already
which that's been covered
um so can we ensure that the development
of this parking strategy
takes into account the the really recent
changes that are taking place
in personal transport we see more and
more electric cars on the road
and already in stone market there are
two retail locations where you can
park your electric car and charge it for
free and i think another couple on the
way
so maybe expecting drivers to park and
pay for charging
that could already be out of date and my
second question is
um paragraph 11.3 talks about
encouraging drivers to consider
more environmentally friendly ways of
traveling
can i ask that the the new parking
strategy doesn't just consider but it
actively promotes using parking to
deliver
mode or shift and that could be you know
free parking and charging for evs
free and secure parking for electric
bicycles
and if we are continuing to charge a fee
for petrol and diesel vehicles
that we consider reinvesting those
charges into supporting
either public transport or the
installation of more charging points
thank you
council fleming
yes thank you um councillor mellon
um in terms of personal transport and
the
changes that are taking place i mean i
think you're right we live in a
um in a in a world that's that's
changing extremely
rapidly and i think i alluded to that in
my previous comments
this strategy needs to be adaptable to
match that
and and i and i'm sure it will be it
needs to be
and in terms of
parking where
the vehicle owner recharges their
vehicle
at the same time i don't think this
strategy here addresses parking charges
that will be done
separately but your comment is noted
um in terms of paragraph 11.3 encourage
more um
more sustainable transport um that we
should be
more forceful in that and i think that
yes i think that goes without saying we
will be doing more to encourage we will
be looking at ways
to really make modal shift happen
particularly you know the whole
business with electric bicycles
e-scooters possibly all of these things
need to be taken into account
and how we deal with them i don't think
we know
this point in time how we're going to
deal with them
we just know we need to set up a
strategy that will deal
with things and will adapt as we move
forward into hopefully
more sustainable ways of travel and less
polluting ways of travel
thank you um council richardson do you
have a question or did you want to
it was a response to um something
counselor well i'm asked but actually uh
council clearly mentioned it in her
response so
it was a mentioning the lc whip okay and
they're all back in place else
in which case we're now going to move
into debate
um councillor davis you were first to
indicate
um yeah nothing i've heard has really
changed my mind in fact if it seems to
me
it's confirmed that we're doing the work
that suffolk county council should be
doing
uh residential car parking spaces
suffolk county council parking on verges
the police
highways you know we're paying for
something and we're
getting a consultation basically to tell
us how many
car parking spaces we've got in in the
car park in the towns
um well what do we do do we make them
smaller and car doors bang against each
other and
get complaints about that or do we make
them larger and therefore
we don't have quite as many spaces so
i'm not convinced by this at all
thank you
thank you council award thanks yeah
well i do actually think a comprehensive
parking strategy is much needed and the
time is right now given that all the new
development that has already taken place
and will be taking place in and around
our towns in the next few years
what i just wanted to mention is given
some highly misleading
inaccurate reporting in the press just
over a week ago
when today's agenda was published and
although that's now partially been
corrected i think it's worth
at this point clarifying what the
strategy will not do
and that is it will not be addressing
the matter of charging for parking
either in baber or mid-suffolk
all the rates charged both districts
have always had their own different
charging
tariffs and we approved a revised
tariffs for baber at our cabinet meeting
february
still incidentally providing a free
period council busby well in excess of
10 minutes
the primary purpose of the strategy is
to ensure that we have the appropriate
parking provision both in quantity and
location to support our growing
population in the years to come
and it not only means ensuring
sufficient off-street parking for
shoppers workers and tourists in our
towns but also
sufficient on-street parking reserve
reserve residence although as already
has been mentioned we must work with the
county on on delivering that
but in terms of the the off street
parking we do need to
uh get a better handle on what we have
now what we're going to need in the next
five to 10 years based on the population
changes based on
how people use our towns so i think that
there is still merit
in in gathering that data because there
will be
significant changes to that on-street
parking provision no doubt
and i know yeah i agree we've got to
consider how we can encourage behavioral
change towards alternative
means of travel but this cannot be the
expense of mayhem on our urban roads
we mustn't artificially restrict parking
to dissuade car use
the car will always remain the only
viable means of transport for most of
our largely rural population
so i'm very supportive of the paper and
also the scope of what will be delivered
as described in the report
thank you thank you council award
councillor i think
yeah i thought um council award was
going to address the issue of
where these costs taught to be showing
them because i have to say i have some
sympathy with what dave busby
said i think that the cost of our car
parking
should be shown in the
well as a cost of car parking and this
is part of it
and council council
as it's already been pointed out our car
parks make a thumping loss
um adding a more money to that will just
um
increase that that problem um
we have money in in the reserve to cover
the cost of this strategy
it's part of our our strategic
priorities and and that's what the
reserve funding is there for
um if if we were making
a small profit out of our parking income
then i could understand that but
um it doesn't make any sense quite
honestly
it does make sense to me because we're
in debate
this is not question and answer session
we are in debate
question is debating with council award
you get one
set of three minutes you've asked
you've had your say well he didn't
respond fully
we've got two minutes ten seconds left
councillor osborne thank you madam
chairman as i alluded to
earlier i do really welcome this
strategy
you know parking is a huge problem
throughout the babel and mid-suffolk
districts
both in our towns and in our rural areas
and a lot of my calls that i get in
emails
is about parking problems and i can't
turn my back on it although it's not
within my remit
but what is within remember is that it
does impact on people's quality of life
and that's where this comes into and i'm
hoping that the outcome from this review
will make some changes
um that's both within our remit and
those within county
and that people's quality of life are
improved without this strategy
that is not going to happen and our
parking problems will continue thank you
madam chan councilman albersi
thank you madam chairman councillor
davis
is right the on-street parking belongs
to suffolk county
but as councillors we should also pick
up on the issues that our residents are
suffering
because of county and we have a
responsibility to manage it up
as well as just managing down
by developing our car parks
we could very well be removing
cars from street parking because we're
making better
efficiency and better use
resident parking
tends to be reasonably expensive
when you look at how it's applied
nationally
so it might encourage people to actually
use the car parks because they may get a
more preferential rate
without the strategy we don't know
without the strategy we can't determine
whether it's turn left or turn right
we need the strategy so that we can
produce a comprehensive policy
of parking that's going to take us
through this interim period where
of rapid change and where hopefully the
pendulum will start to
swing less or should i say more slowly
and we can have a policy that then will
take us forward to
maybe even hydrogen powered cars
who knows and electric vehicle charging
points will become obsolete who knows
but we need the policy and we can't do
the policy without the data
to create the strategy thank you madam
chairman
thank you councillor richardson thank
you chair um there are
three points i wanted to make having
listened to some of the questions and
and
um heard some of the debates um the
first is that
obviously i i accept that there's a
going to be a degree of overlap between
what we're responsible for as district
councils what the county council is
responsible for
but i think it's also important to
recognize that it sets out in the report
that this links very closely to some of
our other corporate priorities
so things like helping our town centers
recover
and our high streets recover from the
pandemic they're making sure customers
can actually gain access to businesses
to help support them
um as well as helping our more urban
areas accommodate future housing growth
so i'm thinking particularly around
stone market for example um
accommodating the housing growth that
will be taking place along the a14
corridor
um so i think it's important going back
to that point around
um working with the county council is
people want to see a joined up approach
to infrastructure when it comes to
housing
and and the provision of parking in in
some of our towns
the second point which i think is
mentioned in paragraph 11.1
um is especially important because it
links to well-being that if we can
encourage this modal shift in
transportation then uh reducing air
pollution and therefore reducing the
amount of particulate matter
um will help to improve uh respiratory
health
which obviously is a very important
aspect of what we're trying to do
with um well-being and the point i was
going to make
earlier which council fleming already
quite rightly mentioned is that that
shift and that promotion of active
travel
is something we can do perfectly in
conjunction with the local cycling and
walking infrastructure plan
so i think therefore focusing on parking
uh ties in very nicely with that
um and finally just to sort of touch on
the point that
councilman alves just mentioned
certainly from my experience with the
leisure sport and physical activity
strategy getting the right technical
expertise and doing the data collection
is an incredibly important exercise even
if it's just understanding
and getting an accurate picture of
demand and supply across the two
districts
because it enables us to better plan and
having that strong evidence base
is i think very important when
developing a strategy like this because
it then helps
inform policy going forward so i think
it's an excellent idea to have a
strategy such as this
and i'll be wholeheartedly supporting
the recommendations in the report
thank you thank you councillor
richardson
for myself this um this is a strategy
it's our strategy it's not county
council's
strategy it's what we want to
find out and implement for
our residents our businesses
and the people who live work and visit
mid-suffolk
so it may well be that the county
council
is part of the solution once we've
finalized the strategy but for me
mid-suffolk needs a parking strategy
and i will be wholeheartedly supporting
this
councillor busby thank you my three
minutes starts now
i've got concerns about this i think
it's going to set expectations that we
can't
uh achieve it's going to identify that
we've got a shortfall in car parking
spaces but we've done nothing in the
past to
provide additional car parking spaces
it's not it's not going to resolve
the planning short-sightedness that
we've had in the 60s 70s 80s
even now where we provide too few car
parking spaces in
residential areas we're not going to
find additional car parking spaces
so i don't see how we're going to
resolve those issues
residence parking permits my experience
in pinewood
is when confronted with the options of a
residence parking permit
residents don't go for it there's a no
no guarantee that they'll get a space
which is one of the things that they
expect
they'll have to pay for it which is
approximately 100 pounds a year they
don't like to do that either
so it doesn't resolve the issues and we
end up with yellow lines all over
residential
estates which may or may not be the
solution
as for measuring demand and supply yes
it will
measure supply i'm not so convinced it
will measure demand
i think it's very difficult to identify
that
so i've got a number of concerns i'm
concerned also it doesn't include
charging i think that's ducking the
issue
i'm concerned that we're charging it to
the wrong thing it should be charged to
car parking
even if we've got a shortfall already in
the in the money that comes in for car
parking
it's part of that process it's nothing
to do with transformation fund it's just
a
we're just using that fund as a means of
spending some money
so i have a lot of concerns about
what will be delivered from this apart
from high expectations
um so i'm
considering not voting for it
thank you councillor brewster thank you
madam chair
um yeah i think that you know there's
there's
one or two different um
pieces of the strategy we need to look
at um
i i think generally yes we need
the strategy for car parking in the
local area for
people who are visiting town uh sorry
not visiting them come to that
um people who live in the town and
people who
work and and uh
use the the um
the things that the town can offer to
them
but we also have a
um the
growth of tourism which we desperately
need
i witnessed that in the stone market on
saturday
where we had the prima donna festival at
the museum
and the car parks um were answering to
that and
uh the ones i tried to use anyway were
were full um
so i hope that the strategy will
actually
take uh notice of
tourism because tourism uh
for economy is extremely good for our
area the whole of mid-south at baber and
where
you wish and i wouldn't like to see that
lost
because something like the prima donna
festival
was extremely successful it had enormous
number of people
from outside the area coming in that was
about 75 percent i understand
so
and i would add that when i did find a
small space on a car park
he went to pay for an all-day pass on
that particular car park
and two ladies behind me when they saw
the cost of it
said oh that's absolutely fantastic you
know we should come here again
so and and it it it helps but i i
realize that stone market is the only
car park in mid-socket which which pays
charges um and the rest of them are free
so i don't think that actually precludes
taking
the strategy into those areas
and see what we can do to actually lift
our tourism industry
in in missouri and indeed in believer
excellent thank you councillor brewster
councillor fleming
thank you i just wanted to very briefly
address what councillor busby was saying
the fact that he um and i think
councillor davis also feel we don't need
this strategy
um i don't think any strategy
is a magic wand and this certainly won't
be
but i think you have to consider what
the do nothing option is
and when you think about doing nothing
and ignoring
trying to put together all the various
pieces of this complicated jigsaw
um i think i sincerely believe
we need this strategy and we need it now
um particularly because things are
changing so much
and particularly to enable us to um to
be able to
help finance the provision of
you know the different types of parking
needs that are coming in the future
thank you everybody nice lively debate
i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
could i ask that the two recommendations
are split so we deal with the
three one three two separately
council board council possibly rather
than that
um i think i'd like to propose an
amendment to recommendation 3.2
in terms of the source of the funding
not to use the transformations strategic
priorities fund
but to fund this from a separate source
um effectively with within the uh
parking account
you're happy with that you're happy with
that and then
keep them together everyone
baby members you're all happy with that
okay thank you
okay and the mid-suffolk recommendations
remain as is
okay thank you henriette
thank you members the votes are now in
progress
i apologize uh if you just give me a
couple of minutes i'll sort that out
thank you
right chad i think we are there now
so chair we have put in the amendment
that to approve the recommendation
uh 3.1 and 3 12.2 with amendment as read
out by the committee clerk
and the 3.2 will read that the funding
of 20
500 for papers contributed contribution
towards the formulation of the parking
strategy
from the paper parking account
be approved yes that's fine thank you
and the vote is now in progress
the vote for papers in progress i'll
start the
vote for mid-suffolk now
sorry chair the vote for mid suffolk
cabinet is nine votes for
and that's unanimous
councillor busby will you be voting
what a guest
thank you chair that is then uh five
votes four and one against
four paper cabinets
thank you very much indeed
so both both of those are carried
and the date and time of the next
meeting
is scheduled for monday the 6th of
september at 10 30
in the chamber thank you everybody for
your
your debate meetings closed at 12 43.
thank you everybody
you